profoundly disturbing to the point of
being unwatchable 2008's Martyrs was one
of the progenitors of the French extreme
horror movement and earned that
distinction in every single way from the
opening sequence which depicts the
chillingly merciless murder of an entire
family the movie only gets harder to
watch it's a curiosity killed the cat
parable about revenge mercy and Humanity
search for meaning and it's unlike
anything you've ever seen it challenges
you to keep watching right up to the
cruel and bitter end but watch the
original rather than the 2016 remake
because that one's scary for a whole
different series of reasons